The Joe Rogan Experience but I want to
talk about uh
chat GPT
[Music]
um
fascinating question yeah have you
experimented with it I have not but
someone uh the the gentleman who runs
the uh JRE companion page
um made a rap with chat GPT
like uh was it was it if Kanye West
wrote a rap for chat GPT they put it on
Instagram but it's it it's like it seems
like a person saying it like you want to
try it no we could try anything you are
I mean it takes a long time he his thing
took like 48 minutes to do well whatever
you want to look up right now we can do
it yeah the problem is you have to
cajole it it'll get something wrong and
you have to let's just explain what it
is so chat GPT is a large language model
trained artificial intelligence which is
let's just say it can be awful but it is
often surprisingly good at answering
questions you might have about how to do
things one of the great triumphs of it
is that coders are now asking it to
solve coding problems and it will
actually write code that is functional
it's pretty amazing and it also there's
a an implementation of it that if you
feed it up to three tweets it will write
a New York Times story in one of five
genres you know optimistic pessimistic
neutral and
um you know it's you don't really need
the New York Times anymore because it's
pretty good at this job right so on the
one hand it's all very interesting that
we're living in an era in which there is
at least I mean you know and this is a
prototype right this is a prototype that
was specifically trained and then placed
on the internet so people could play
with it and I've seen lots of
interesting
uses it's going to get better right
we're dealing with chat GPT 3 there's
going to be a chat gpt4 which is going
to be that much better because it will
be built with the uh improvements that
have been gained through turning this
one loose on the world but I have to say
I am
quite alarmed
not only that this thing exists but I
don't think we're ready for it
and I don't think we're ready for it in
a couple different ways I mean if you
wanna
Comfort yourself and say well this isn't
that serious that we have this AI that
can do these really shocking things the
the comforting thing is that the way
it's programmed it doesn't know what
it's saying it doesn't matter that it
convinces you that it's
saying something and it means it and you
know that it seems like a creative
entity what it's doing is it is
basically
using a predictive model that has been
trained on a huge data set of written
language right so the answer is if you
know you take three words in a row can
you predict what the next word is going
to be and they've allowed it they've
exposed it to a large data set and it's
gotten really good at predicting
basically these sequences to the point
that it can now if you're prompted
correctly it can spit out these uh
very long explanation some of them are
dead wrong sometimes they're right on
target
but I have two concerns about it
one if you imagine that this thing just
gets a little better than it is which is
inevitable
that it's going to make
actual Insight that much harder to spot
right in other words if you become
expert at operating this thing at
querying it and it becomes better at
understanding a wider range of topics
because they turn it loose on everything
that's written on the internet for
example right then the point is the
ability to fake expertise
is going to go through the roof
I don't think we know how we're going to
police a world in which I mean this is
this problem is already bad enough
most academics
are fakers
they don't know that right they trained
in something they wrote a dissertation
they think they're experts but you can
see when something unexpected happens
like the pandemic you get just broad
scale failure across entire disciplines
where nobody seems to get it right right
so in that world this is going to be
even worse because now you have some an
artificial intelligence
able to generate things in plain English
that are often full of true information
but you don't know whether what
generated it is some
you know brain dead model or something
else that's one concern and then the
other concern is
when we say well
Chachi PT doesn't know what it's saying
it's not conscious we know it's not
conscious because it's not programmed to
have a consciousness
we are actually ignoring the other half
of the story which is that we don't know
how human consciousness works and we
don't know how it develops in a child
right a child is exposed
to a world of adults talking around them
and the child experiments first with
phonemes and then words and then
clusters of words and then sentences and
by doing something that isn't all that
far from what chat TPT is doing it ends
up becoming a conscious individual and
so
I think it's clear that chat GPT isn't
conscious it couldn't be but it isn't
clear to me at least that we are not
suddenly stepping on to a process that
produces that very quickly without us
even necessarily knowing it
and what steps if any can be done to
mitigate that at this point
well it's interesting I I wrote a paper
which I never published anywhere in I
think 2016 about this very issue in fact
I used
um basically the argument that you could
you could attain artificial general
intelligence by imbuing computers with a
childlike play environment for language
and then exposing them to a huge data
set which is not exactly what's happened
here but it's in the ballpark
um and I would argue and I did argue
that one needs to build a
um an architecture in which this can't
get away from you
right and so the architecture that I
advocate for is actually a metamorphosis
architecture where metamorphosis is not
allowed it is an affirmative choice of
humans
so in other words if you think about
let's say that we developed some
artificial frogs to do some job to clear
some Waterway of something
um and we imbued them with an
intelligence so they could learn to
clear the Waterway better but we worried
that they might learn to do something
that we don't want them to do
and that we would have no way of
arresting it once these frogs were
released in the wild and capable of
producing more of themselves but if what
you say is well at the point at which
you go from a tadpole to a frog you have
to ask us if you can go right there's no
uh there's no Automatic Transition from
a tadpole to a frog there are still
dangers right in the case of GPT chat
you know I think some of the the
artificial intelligence existential risk
folks would tell you that one of the
dangers
is that the
um
the chat AI could convince you to do its
bidding right as you said when you were
looking at this it felt like a person
right and the point is something that
feels like a person can play on your
emotions right can that be used to to
cause a Fail-Safe to be removed Maybe
but in any case this only deals with one
of the two issues I'm raising the
question of actual artificial general
intelligence arriving us not knowing
necessarily that it has right that's a
frightening Prospect
um and in fact I have a little thought
experiment that might reveal why but the
other issue is the issue of competence
in a world where you know you basically
have uh
you know you have a
Cyrano de Bergerac dystopia where
everybody is using this thing behind the
scenes in order to say things that are
beyond their own capacity to articulate
right then the world becomes some new
kind of Hall of Mirrors we've had a hard
enough time dealing with algorithms on
uh you know on search and feed this is a
whole next level of difficulty in
knowing where you are and who you're
talking to and what it means and what
their motives are and
um
I think we ought to be on high alert
when you extrapolate when you look at
what this does and what it's capable of
and
what I think what scares people is
something that seems to be a person
but doesn't have any emotion doesn't
have any
soul
it doesn't it's not us
but it behaves exactly as us
and then you can put it in a physical
entity so if you have this chat GPT and
then you extrapolate to version five six
seven eight nine ten and then there's a
physical thing
that has this ability inside of it to
communicate with you like ex machina
where it's
exhibiting all of the behavior
characteristics of a person like one of
the most terrifying that's one of my
favorite movies of all time I love that
movie one of my favorite movies of all
time was when that guy
who was brought in to uh sort of run
some tests on these artificial
intelligence creations and determine
whether or not they pass as human what
is that test called again the um during
test Turing test yeah and um
he is in love with this woman she's
manipulated him to the point where he's
aided her in her escape and then she
leaves him in that room with the
bulletproof glass and he's pounding on
the glass and she walks away with not a
thought at all about him
it is the ultimate example of the worst
case scenario of where this can go where
you have something that behaves exactly
like a human being and knows how to play
upon your sexual urges your emotional
desires all of those different things
that she plays upon
and then she just walks away from him
and leaves him to starve to death in
this [ __ ] bulletproof room
yeah
um and you know I'm now recalling the
film and it's it's done very well
because it manipulates you passively in
your seat yes right as it manipulates
this character on the screen and so you
are betrayed too yes in this you want to
believe that it's emotional and it has
none of that you feel bad for this woman
what you think is a woman who is uh
contained and you know when she's sang
to him when the power goes out don't
trust him and then you know the power
comes back on she behaves normally again
you're like oh my God like she's trapped
right like this poor creature they've
made an a person essentially and she has
these thoughts and hopes and dreams just
like a regular person but now she's
trapped and he falls in love with her
and even though he's seen her in her
robot form when she puts skin on and
when she puts clothes on
when she's in front of him he's in love
with her right and it you know again it
plays very well because
uh there's a manipulable circuit in
straight men yeah right that's going to
react to this I'm sure straight women as
well I'm sure Gay women gay men no doubt
everybody well yes but in this
particular narrative right but it means
to be a gay woman or a straight man
right for it to trigger you but
um but a part of this is actually
inevitable in the chat GPT story because
especially to the extent that this is a
Mindless entity that doesn't know what
it's doing it's just striving to do it
better yes the tactics that work will
register is oh you did it right so to
the extent that you have those
vulnerabilities in you and it finds them
and that works then the point is
reinforcement right it scares us because
it's not us
but it is us well because it's it's
behaving exactly like us but it doesn't
have all the things that make a person a
person it doesn't have the biological
vulnerabilities it doesn't have the the
ability to actually sexually reproduce
it doesn't have emotions it doesn't have
all these different things that we like
to think of the Soul you know whatever
that means whatever that term actually
means yeah but I'm worried about what
could be generated and I know that that
sounds it will sound to a lot of people
especially technological people like a
biologist out of his depth but I don't
think so this is a biologist trying to
say something about the biology and what
it applies about this analogous system